We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. it's
been a while since we heard from furious.
Trump is Jimmy from Philly.
But he did leave a voicemail and it was about
president Bernie Sanders.
Take a listen to this.
David, Jimmy from Philly regarding your comment.
President Bernie Sanders.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
okay.
Something about that laugh feels a little
too really maniacal.
I somehow don't think that that's a joke,
but in any case, I don't know what Jimmy is
referring to specifically.
I did say I am a Bernie Warren guy.
But beyond that, I think that there is going
to be plenty of time for laughing after the
election.
There will be plenty of time for crying after
the election.
All emotions are going to be on the table
and visible after the election.
Uh, but for the time being, I don't know that
I have much more of a response, uh, to Jimmy
from Philly.
We will talk on the bonus show today about
Hillary Clinton's very interesting interview
with Howard stern.
We will talk about that art Basel Miami, $120,000
banana thing.
I, there are some interesting things to talk
about.
If you haven't heard about it, I'll tell you
all about it.
And a new report found that the United States
lost more tax revenue than any other developed
country in 2018 due to the Donald Trump tax
cuts.
All of those stories and more on
the bonus
show@joinpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
I'll speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].